après l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire le 15 octobre dernier visant
la société ikea industries france c'est
son directeur général un ressortissant
allemand de 54 ans qui est cette fois-ci
mise en examen pour homicides
involontaires dans le cadre du travail
par manquement à une obligation de
sécurité
l'anc est en réalité au début avait
montré des failles importantes absence
de dispositif pour prévenir la collision
entre la machine et tout piéton sur le
site est effectivement l'enquète
montrent qu' il n'y a pas de délégation
pouvoir c'est à dire que c'est lui bien
sûr qui est donc le responsable de ses
manquements à des règles de sécurité
le 21 août le responsable de la zone de
chargement du parc à bois de
l'entreprise de lure avait été écrasé
par un engin le conducteur n'avait pas
vu son collègue le travail des
enquêteurs a débouché sur un constat
d'absence de consignes de prudence et de
sécurité
on a constaté effectivement que que la
machine
le godet de la machine était surchargé
donc avait aucune visibilité qui avait
un bruit très important qui est réalisé
par la broyeuse donc on n'entend rien et
en plus on s'est rendu compte qu'elle
ait pas de consignes particulières de
sécurité sur le site
le directeur général de la société a été
remis en liberté dans le cadre d'un
cautionnement de 60000 euros avec
l'obligation de se présenter tous les 15
jours à la gendarmerie de lure il
encourt une peine de trois ans de prison
il qu'hier industries france personne
morale est passible d'une amende de 225
mille euros